-We're back with Tina Fey.
Congratulations on the "Kimm
Schmidt" interactive special
What gave you
the idea or the impetus
to do a choose-your-own
adventure "Kimmy Schmidt"?
-Yes, well, first of all,
legally I think we're not
allowed to refer to it as
"choose your own adventure."
-Gotcha. Well, I think legally
I can call it whatever I want.
-You can -- You can go nuts.
[ Laughs ]
But what happened was, we were
finishing shooting the series,
the body of the series,
and right as we were
finishing up
that last part
of that last season,
Netflix came to us and said,
"We have this technology that --
We're about to do this sho
called 'Bandersnatch'
on 'Black Mirror,'" which --
I don't know if
you saw "Bandersnatch."
-I did.
-It was a really cool
"Black Mirror" special
that was a very dark, moody,
super-cool version
of this technology
where you're watching it
and then you, the viewer,
with your remote, make choices
of what the character does
And they said --
They showed it to us early
which was really cool,
and then they said,
"Do you think you could do thi
with 'Kimmy Schmidt'?"
And we were like, "120 percent,"
because, one, it just
was such exciting technology
and, two, our show
is kind of known for
kind of having too many jokes...
-Yes.
-...going on.
And so it was a way to write
as many jokes as you want
but not choke people with them
all at once.
So if you --
This is an interactive special
We've called it a movie a lot.
I don't know.
It's called
an interactive special.
And basically Kimmy is about t
get married to a royal --
a British royal, distant
British royal named Frederick.
Prince Frederick, who is playe
by Daniel Radcliffe,
who's awesome.
And then in time she finds out
that the reverend --
She makes a discovery
that makes her concerned
that there's another bunke
somewhere
that hasn't been discovered,
so she has to make some choice
as to how far she'll go to try
to find this other bunker,
and you get to make
these choices with her.
Now, you also
get to make choices --
You'll appreciate this
as a writer,
'cause Netflix was like,
"You know, so, 'Bandersnatch
was one story,
so you'll probably want
to keep it to one story,
because it's
pretty impossible to track."
We were like, "Cool, cool, cool.
So three stories."
-[ Laughs ]
-We were just so used to
Being able to cut away
to the other story...
-Sure.
-...like, momentum-wise.
Please hold. There's
a colonial lady coming in.
Yes. Can I help you?
-[ Laughs ]
I'm sorry.
You're not making sound. What?
I'm -- Yes. Hello.
-Hello.
-We're taping
a television program.
Do you need something?
-I did the interactive --
I clicked for her entry.
-[ Giggling ]
-The colonial lady
just called us losers!
-Wait a second!
We're not losers!
-This means "loyalists"
in colonial times,
so that's on you!
Hold on. Um...
So -- Oh, wait.
So did you say you played it
-There's a joke --
This really speaks back
to how you layer jokes
on jokes on jokes.
Even the theme song
has a joke in it.
-Yes. Should we -- Hmm.
I don't know
if we should give it away.
-You don't have to give it away,
but I guess the --
-But I will say, though, there's
the thing with the theme song,
that if you -- like any
Netflix show, when it starts
you have the option
to skip intro.
And, you know,
my husband, Jeff Richmond,
one of our EPs on the show
also wrote that theme song
which I think is one of
the greatest TV theme song
of all time.
-It is one of the greatest
TV theme songs of all time
I completely echo
that sentiment.
And yet, I imagine that if you
watch a bunch in a row...
like, you might at some poin
maybe go like,
"Oh, I'll skip the song."
-Right.
Or if you're my older daughter
and your dad wrote that song
and you've heard it a lot of
times just being re-recorded
around the house, you might --
Because I was showing it
to my older daughter early
an early copy,
and the theme song came up
and "skip intro" came up,
and she literally, like,
looked around to make sure
that her dad was not aroun
and then hit "skip intro,"
and I knew that there was,
like, a surprise coming.
There's -- Something
slightly punitive happens
when you hit "skip intro."
So...watch that unfold.
-You are actually going to
head over to 30 Rock today
-Yes, I think by the time
me and you are talking on TV
I will have already been there
We're doing a --
I guess it's a telethon.
-Yeah.
-It's the "Rise Up New York!
telethon tonight at 7:00 p.m
And I am going down
to kind of host the live portion
of it from NBC.
I feel really excited
and privileged
to get -- to go into NBC.
You know, I think --
I'm sure you feel the same way
that we just long to be --
The only way
we remotely know how to help
is to go on TV and try to talk
So I'm going to go down ther
today and hopefully read
some impressive
fundraising totals.
-That's great. Thank you
so much for doing that.
And we will put up
the information,
because that will have happene
before our show,
but we'll put it up now if
people want to donate to that.
And it is always such a deligh
to talk to you, Tina.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Do not miss
"Kimmy Schmidt Interactive."
It's fantastic. It's on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."